- Hello Believe Nation.
Today I'm going to talk
about the seven ways
to structure your day for success.
- [Computerized Voice] Nine, eight.
(hip hop music)
- So one of the most common
questions that I get asked,
is how do I structure my day?
How do I set up my schedule,
my time, to have success?
Consistently.
Be productive.
Because as an entrepreneur,
you've got a million things going on.
You're wearing every hat in the business.
And, oh by the way,
you want a personal life, as well.
So today I'm going to share with you
the seven ways to structure
your day for optimal success.
Way number one is you need
to have a morning routine.
You need to have a morning
routine that inspires you,
that gets you set up from the beginning,
from the start of every single day
to set you up for success.
This is one of the biggest things
that entrepreneurs need help with
because, maybe you watch this video,
on a Thursday afternoon at five o'clock,
and you're working so hard,
you get so inspired and motivated,
or maybe you're meeting somebody.
Or maybe you listen to
a podcast or something.
Think about what gets you so inspired
because, often what happens,
is then you have tons of productivity,
and then you wake up the
next day and it's gonea
and you're starting over
and the alarm goes off
and you're sluggish,
getting out of bed and
you don't want to do it.
And you slowly grind into your day.
Until some other random thing happens,
and that gets you fired up
and you're off and running.
And instead of having
these peaks and valleys,
where you're up and down and up and down,
you're riding this roller coaster,
you want to think about
what gets you most excited,
motivated, inspired, productive,
and plan that into your
morning routine daily.
To give yourself the best shot,
at having a productive day today,
where you're going to go
off and have a big impact.
Where you believe in the big,
crazy dream that you have,
that you can make it happen.
Put that into your morning routine.
And so for everybody it's
a little bit different.
Some of the common themes,
it could be having music.
I love putting music on
first thing in the morning.
Something that gets me
inspired and pumped up,
and moving, and dancing.
I love watching videos.
The top 10's.
The mentor me's.
I love reading books.
I love having a exercise routine.
Things that get me going.
This is what works for me.
You need to find what works for you
and the best way to do it
is think about when you
have already been inspired.
Because you have.
'Cause you may not wake
up every day inspired,
but you have been inspired
in your life before.
Chances are it's happened recently to you.
What happened that led
to that inspiration?
And, again, instead of letting that thing
be this random occurrence
plan for it daily into
your morning routine
to set yourself up for a successful day.
Number two is ask yourself the question.
The most important question
that you can ask yourself
every single day is what is the most value
I can bring to my business today?
This is something I'm obsessed with.
And every day as I'm
walking to the office,
or walking here to Toronto Dance Salsa,
I'm thinking about what's
the most value that I can
bring to my business today.
Because you have a ton
of things on your plate.
Right?
Entrepreneurs that I know,
have a to do list this long,
followed by an ideas list
which is even longer.
Right?
Sound familiar?
You need to focus on the thing
that's going to bring the most immediate,
impactful value to your business.
Especially if you're a solo entrepreneur.
Especially if you don't have a team
to take care of some
of the things for you.
When you are literally doing
everything in your business
ask yourself every day what
is the highest value task
that I can do today that
will advance my goals.
And then go and do that.
Number three is have CEO time.
This ties into the last point.
You need to make sure
that every single day,
when you're going to your business,
whether that is actually
going to an office,
if you're sitting down in
front of your computer at home,
or going to a Starbucks,
that you have CEO time every day.
And CEO time, what I
consider to be CEO time,
is time to focus on the business
instead of in the business.
Or yes, you have a million things to do.
You've got tons of emails to get back to.
You've got lots of social
media to post out there.
Everybody wants a piece of you.
And you've got an ideas list,
again, that's a mile long.
You need to have CEO time.
I recommend at least 90
minutes a day of CEO time.
Where you're not just caught,
in the day-to-day running of the business,
and stuck on that mouse wheel.
You're just going around
and around and around
and around in circles.
If you don't ever have
time to focus on planning,
and the bigger picture of your business,
then guess what?
You're never going to
get to the bigger picture
for your business.
You're going to stay stuck where you are.
So plan CEO time every
day into your business.
I prefer it in the morning.
I prefer it before you open up your email,
before you let your day explode on you.
'Cause you wake up.
You go to the office.
You look at your email.
And suddenly, your day is over.
You're just constantly
responding to other people.
So whether you call it eat that frog,
or first priorities first,
or lots of people have
different names for it.
Making sure that you plan
that into your schedule
before your day blows
up on you is important
if you want to escape where you are.
Because otherwise, you're
going to stay here.
Instead of being able to grow out here.
Number four is chunk your time.
Anything that you do
multiple times per day,
you want to try to chunk it
down to one time per day.
It makes a huge, huge, huge
difference in your productivity,
in how you structure it,
so that you can get more
important stuff done.
And the classic one is
emails or phone calls.
Because, if somebody emails
you and you look at it,
even if you don't address it immediately,
it's still, you're thinking about it.
And it distracted you from
doing what you should be doing.
Which is whatever task you're working on.
And this is especially important
when you're doing creative tasks.
When I'm working on my book,
when I'm writing the manuscript,
when I'm doing important research.
I'm so in the zone of focus there
that if you tap me on the shoulder,
or you send me an email,
or you try to call me,
I don't have a phone but,
you try to call me,
it takes me half an hour just
to get back to where I was.
So that five second
interruption isn't really
a five second interruption.
You've screwed over a
good chunk of my day.
And so thinking about those
important things that happened
to you multiple times per day,
how do you chunk that down
so I'm only doing it one time a day,
I'm focused on just
doing that for the day,
and it means that you lose,
you lose some small potential wins.
Right?
Like if you're only
checking email at 12 o'clock
as an example,
then maybe some really important
media opportunity comes up
and they need an answer by 11 o'clock.
And you didn't see it in time and so,
you don't get that media opportunity.
You can't get every single small win.
It's not going to happen.
It's not possible.
You can't be on 24/7.
It is not possible.
And so you have to be comfortable
with losing some of the small wins
because the time that your
spending that is so focused
is allowing you to go create
something bigger and amazing.
Chunk your daily time.
Number five is chunk your week.
So just like we chunk multiple
times per day to once a day,
anything you're doing
multiple times per week,
do once per week.
So I look at the filming
videos as an example.
I film all the videos for my channel
pretty much on a Wednesday afternoon.
I'll stand here at Toronto Dance Salsa,
I'll set up the lights and
the gear and the camera
and the books and the
microphone and all that,
and make 20 videos for the week.
And it does a couple of things.
Why is this so important?
Like why not do three videos a day?
Instead of 20 videos in one day.
One, because there's setup
time and take down time.
This applies to anything.
Whatever you want to get into,
whatever tasks you have,
there's set up time and take down time.
For this,
I need to set up the lights
and the camera and the books,
and the microphone and all that stuff.
I need to get it all ready.
And so it's much more time saving
for me to do it all at once,
all the videos at once,
instead of having that setup
and take down time each time.
The second thing is task
switching is difficult.
So when I'm in video
mode, I'm in video mode.
I'm just focused on the videos.
I can bring the energy from
one video to the next video
to the next video, where
it's so hard for me
to go from video mode,
extrovertive, energy,
enthusiasm, into research mode
where it's headphones on,
don't talk to me, introverted, analyzing,
try to figure stuff out.
And to take me from that state,
introverted, getting work done,
to hey come and be on a video,
I'm going to have energy like this.
I'm going to be distracted.
I'm not going to be as upbeat.
I'm going to be thinking
about other things
and it won't be a good video.
Even now, I already have less energy.
Who wants this on video?
And so, understanding that
your energy will change
with different kinds
of tasks is important.
And so whatever is happening
multiple times per week,
try to do it on one day per week.
So for me, what my
schedule looks like now,
Monday I'm working on
all the video research,
for this channel.
Reviewing all the videos,
seeing what has to be changed,
what I like, what I don't like.
Making modifications.
And in the afternoon, I'm
doing book promotion work.
Could be research again on the book
or it could be reaching out to influencers
or could be making thank-you videos.
I'm kind of in that zone.
Tuesdays, I spend the
whole afternoon doing
Toronto Dance Salsa work.
Wednesdays, I'm doing
videos all afternoon.
Thursdays, I'm doing phone calls
and interviews and meetings.
And, then Friday, is my CEO day.
When I'm spending the whole day doing
CEO bigger picture stuff.
And it really, really,
really, really, really,
really, works and, again,
you have to be willing
to give up the small
wins to go for the big wins.
Number six is value your time.
I don't think people
value their time enough.
I don't think entrepreneurs
If I audited your day and
looked at what you were
actually doing the day, there'd
be a lot of wasted time.
All the time you spend
on Facebook, or clicking
refresh on your statistics,
to see how many people watch
your YouTube videos in the past hour
and going back and checking again.
Or checking your sales numbers
over and over and over and over again.
Yes you could work harder.
Yes you can add more hours to your day.
Because you need to get more work done.
But I would say that a huge
chunk of your current day,
even if you worked zero extra hours,
could be way more productive
because you're just not focused.
And that's a harsh truth.
That's something that's hard
to say and hard to realize.
But if you look at your schedule,
you look at the tasks you're
actually doing during the day,
and you constantly self-audit to say,
is this really the best use of my time?
And then start to make
adjustments based off of that.
Because a lot of entrepreneurs
complain that they don't
have enough time, but really,
you're not valuing your time enough.
And you're doing things
that you shouldn't be doing.
And number seven is to invest in yourself.
I'd make sure that you find time
at least once a week, if not every day,
to invest in yourself.
To learn.
To grow.
To try new things.
To make yourself better.
Because as you grow,
as you gain in knowledge and experience,
and expertise, your business will grow.
And so that could be,
meditation, works really
well for some people.
It could be gratitude.
I have a daily gratitude
practice that I do
every single day to remind
me of the things that I have
and I'm fortunate in my life.
It could be watching videos
to learn and be inspired.
It could be reading.
It could be trying to
understand a new topic.
It fills you.
It makes you feel better.
It puts you in a better mood.
And it gives you more
of not just inspiration
but also the tactics of what to do.
One of the things that really
helped me in my early days
as an entrepreneur, was reading this book,
Radicals and Visionaries,
every single morning.
And it was just three or four pages
of a different entrepreneur
that helped me get in the
zone of being inspired
but also, give me some
tactics of what I could do.
And so now, I don't read the book anymore,
but I watch videos.
And it gives me the
motivation and also the ideas
of what I can do.
And so you need to make sure
that you're spending time
at least every week investing in yourself.
Factor that in.
Don't let it happen by accident
or randomly on the weekends somewhere.
Book it into your calendar
every single week,
for every single day,
so you are constantly
learning and growing.
So that's my view on the seven
ways to structure your day
for success.
I'm curious to figure out
what did you guys think?
What did you guys like the most?
What did you agree with?
Or what did you not agree with?
And would you add an eight,
nine, ten to the list?
Something I missed out?
Let me know.
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Darja Bardo.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word,
It really, really, really,
really, means a lot to me.
So thank you guys for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.